let's get to five headlines
[Music]
so joe biden went to kenosha yesterday
we'll get right to the uh
we'll get right to the inevitable joe
biden moment while speaking to people at
a church
you know he got away from race-baiting
and throwing police under the bus
for a moment to talk about taxes for
some reason but then then he stopped
himself
and um this happened
19 making a billion dollars apiece
don't pay a single penny in taxes i'm
not trying to punish anybody but
everyone should pay a fair share
i can lay out free i won't now because
they'll shoot me but here's the deal
they'll shoot me yeah joe not the best
joke given the circumstances
earlier in the day uh the the biden
campaign
speaking of race-baiting released an ad
and uh it is
i almost hesitated to say because
there's so much competition but it is
perhaps the most disingenuous
and misleading political ad i've ever
seen in my life
here's how that went why in this nation
and black americans
wake up knowing that they can lose their
lives in the course of just living their
life
part of the point of freedom is to be
free from brutality
from injustice from racism and all of
its manifestations
we have to let people know that we not
only understand
their struggle but they understand the
fact they deserve to be treated with
dignity they've got to know
we're listening reforming policing in
this country
means creating a national standard on
use of force
and conditioning federal funds for
police departments on adoption of that
standard
it's about reining in qualified immunity
we hold police officers accountable
i can't turn away now is the time for
racial justice
i believe with every fiber in my being
we have such an opportunity now
to change people's lives for the better
it's about who we are
what we believe and maybe most
importantly who we want to be
now is the time for racial justice he
says
at the age of 78 after spending like
five decades in public service
now is the time it wasn't before joe
you're just deciding right now is the
time
i mean you've just now decided that
white supremacist police officers are
out murdering black people
uh in droves and we should stop them did
you not want to stop them before
or did you only recently decide that
this problem existed
if so what made you decide that joe
i could ask the same question about when
you exactly decided that women can have
penises and men can get pregnant because
that apparently you believe now also
that seems to be a you know a rather new
point of view and a kind of a strange
point of view for a person to
adopt in their 70s biden lived his whole
life then got to the age of like 75
suddenly he woke up in a world
where racist cops are murdering black
people and men are running around having
babies
he never never mentioned anything about
any of this before
now all of a sudden though he's talking
about this has got to be the weirdest
flip-flop in american history and the
media
never asks him about it he's never asked
to justify it never
they never say hey joe when did these
hallucinations begin
also in the ad joe asks why in this
nation do black americans wake up
knowing that they could lose their life
in the course of just living their life
uh that what that's the case for all
americans
and all people everyone eventually loses
their life in the course of living their
life
when else are you going to lose it
you're going to lose your life after
you've already lost it
are you going to lose your life while
not in the course of living it
makes no sense but of course what he
means to imply
is that racist cops are prowling the
streets executing black people in mass
that's what he means to say there
that's what he's getting at and again we
go back to
when did joe biden develop these
paranoid delusions
he never mentioned it before now it's a
thing
uh because of course these claims um
about
racist you know black people have to
live in fear because racist white people
are out
are out hunting and killing them you
know completely disconnected from
reality
there is no evidence of any kind
period to support it joe biden knows
that though
but um you know if he has to inflame
racial tensions and
you know all of that um in order to
grasp on to power so he can live the
last
few years of his barely sentient life at
this point
um you know having the power that he's
thirsted for his whole life then then
then
he'll he's fine he'll do that he'll help
just
destroy the country on his way out the
door great guy great guy that joe biden
what a decent what a decent decent man
that joe biden is
a such a decent man
[Music]
number two uh speaking of decent men
michael reinold the man who murdered
the trump supporter in portland was
shot dead by law enforcement yesterday
while they tried to arrest him
the u.s marshal say that he pulled a gun
while they were trying to apprehend him
and he was killed
and now i say this in all sincerity
you know i i really am curious to see if
reinhold is the first white man killed
by law enforcement that blm decides to
get outraged about i really don't know i
have no idea it's kind of 50 50. if they
uh not that there's any reason to be
outraged by it but that hasn't generally
stopped blm in the past
so i'm just curious if they'll break
their policy of ignoring white death
entirely
for rhino i guess we'll see all right
now
to the daily wire has the report
as i pull it up here it is the
california state senate passed a
controversial reform to its sex offender
registry monday that would allow a young
adult who has gay sex with a minor to
escape
registering in some cases for the sex
offender registry
based on a judge's discretion sb 145
finally passed the 40 40-member state
senate by a vote of 23-10
after being introduced by california
state senator scott weiner
weiner argued that the current law
discriminates against lgbt youth because
as the chronicle explained
under current law judge could decide
whether to place a man who has vaginal
intercourse with an underage teenage
girl on the sex offender registry
based on the facts of the case but if
anal or oral sex or vaginal penetration
with anything other than a penis is
involved
the adult must register as a sex
offender
under sb145 a young adult has gay sex
with a minder with a minor 14 or older
who is less than 10 10 years younger
a judge will have the discretion whether
to place the individual
on the sex offender registry
okay and as you heard there the
justification being given for this
is that um in in some cases
when a heterosexual man vaginally rapes
a child
uh they are not put on the sex defender
registry and so as weiner is
arguing here the same should go for
gay men um
i don't think i i really don't think i
need to
spend time explaining the problem with
this logic
but i you know i spend most of my show
explaining logic that probably doesn't
need to be explained so we'll do it here
too
the obvious problem here is is is if
you're going to pass a bill
to address this disparity the bill
should be a
one that that ensures that men who
vaginally rape children
go to jail and are treated and are
treated more harshly than they are
that's the problem
okay that's that's what we need to
address
if in california there could be cases
where a
24 because this is the implications you
could have a
24 year old man raping a 14 year old
child
and they they might not go on sex
offender registry for that that's the
way the law is set up
at least if it's vaginal rape you know
man woman vaginal rape um
or man-child i should say okay well
yes i agree let's pass a law about that
but let's pass a law that does away with
that insanity
and ensures that a man who does that
goes to prison how about i don't know
forever you know at a minimum
i could think of harsher penalties also
that we could consider
but no what uh what the democrats are
saying is no
let's make it even what they're saying
is if this kind of child rape is legal
then this kind of child rape over here
should also be legal
what kind of degenerate lunacy is that
and this guy has you know he's going
around the media uh complaining and
making a martyr of himself because all
the death threats he's getting
of course death threats are bad nobody
supports death threats but if people are
angry at him
it's because he's trying to
decriminalize certain forms of child
rape
and the argument he's making in favor of
it is that well that kind is legal
disgusting ridiculous
repulsive but that's a democrat party
for you that's the democrat party
not just in california but everywhere
all right let's move on uh
number four i actually forgot number
four i have number four written down
here
for my five headlines and i never wrote
a number four this is a professional
operation so we're gonna skip right over
number four
uh maybe we could talk maybe number four
was going to be maybe number four is
going to be the
the uh atlantic story about
donald trump you've probably heard by
now or they're claiming unnamed sources
claiming that
donald trump is was insulting you know
wounded veterans and calling them losers
and
he didn't want to visit a grave of a
veteran
cemetery because he said they're losers
because they died
all unnamed sources no one on the record
and um
and it's you know if something like that
actually happened and he actually said
that and
you're in the administration or you
heard it
then you go on the record
and tell your story the unnamed sources
thing no
and by the way at least five name
sources have come out
and denied this and said so you've got
all the named sources are saying it
didn't happen
only the unnamed sources are saying it
did so you decide how to interpret that
but
i'll tell you how to interpret it it's
bs okay number five prince harry and
megan
have signed apparently a mega netflix
deal
they're going to be producing a whole
bunch of documentaries and other shows
most of the content about themselves
presumably
um i'm just wondering who would want to
watch this
i don't know aren't these two two of the
most boring people on earth
and i say this i i'm sincerely perplexed
here
why would anyone care what they're doing
with their lives
who wants to hear from these two could
there be anything less
interesting than the story of two rich
people who don't have jobs
i mean nothing against them if i could
have a life like that i'd take it but
i'm not going to pretend that my life is
interesting what a reality
show of these two consists of what would
be the conflict
that drives the narrative they have a
disagreement about what kind of
caviar to serve at their two-year-old's
birthday party you know i i don't know
anyway the l.a times has a statement
from the couple this is what the
statement says
um our lives both independent of each
other and as a couple
have allowed us to understand the power
of the human spirit
of courage resilience and the need for
connection
though our work with diverse communities
and their environments
through our work with diverse
communities and their environments to
shining a light on people and causes
around the world
our focus will be on creating content
that informs but also gives hope
oh my gosh did they just
call themselves courageous and resilient
is did they just say the lesson that
they've taken from their life
experiences
is the value of courage
they did didn't they and it goes on
harry and megan whose son archie is 15
months old
added that making inspirational family
program amazing important to them as
is quote powerful storytelling through a
truthful and relatable lens
they say that netflix's reach will help
them quote share impactful content
that unlocks action what
they're also committed to amplifying
diverse voices in the front of
in front of and behind the camera as
well as diverse hiring practices for
roles or filling out their production
company i'm gonna be sick
i would honestly rather be skinned alive
and thrown into a fire
filled with snakes burning snakes
burning snakes with hepatitis
i would rather that than spend five
seconds
watching anything these two produce
but uh congrats to them on their netflix
still i'm sure it'll be great
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on
all of our future content